Today February 27th, 2015 and I'm going to interview
Virginia Amato.
Hello, Virginia. Tell me what makes you different from other individuals
What makes me different from other individuals is I suffer from bipolar
disorder and some people
don't understand what that is. But me I hear
voices. I see things that normal people
don't see and
that's, um
basically
my outlook on life right now is that I'm trying to cope with
My disability and educating people about it too
Do you live
at home. Yes I do. What do you like about yourself.
I like about myself is that I'm
a caring, loving, sweet person. I
have a wonderful family that's behind me and
[pause]
I enjoy life. What do you dislike about yourself.
I dislike about myself uh my ability to want to eat a
lot of food and just
[pause]
Trying hard not to do that because I don't want to go back to the weight that I used to be
.
So you must have worked very hard on that. Yes, I worked very hard.
I had the lap band surgery and it was a long struggle to get to where I am now
.
Let me ask you do you consider your life difficult?
No, not really. Not really. I don't consider my life difficult I consider that I
have a great life.
Can I ask you who has been the most important person in your life? My mother.
Can you tell me what the most important lesson you've learned from your
Mom?
The most important lesson I learned from my mom is she is a
kind, sweet person that has taught me that even though I have a
disability I am as normal as any other person out there.
there. (repeated in tool, not in actual story)
I have a quote from a poet.
The only person you are destined to become is the person you decide to be.
Tell me what person did you, Virginia Amato, decide to be?
Me, myself, and I that's who I decided to be.
I want you to finish this sentence for me. I draw my strength from ___
My family.
Because without them in my life I would just
be another person probably locked away in an insane asylum somewhere
just being mistreated because of a disability that people don't understand
Thank you, Virginia, your story is beautiful. Thank you. Thank you
I'm honored that you shared it with me. You're welcome. It's going to forever be preserved
. Thank you.